all right guys
bang bang i've got tour here how you
doing man thank you so much for doing
this
dude it's my pleasure thanks so much for
having me on
absolutely i know you're serious about
this because you got the real deal
headphones you got the microphone
attached you're ready to go
yes i i attached my microphone so you
could hear me i put the headphones on
noise canceling mode so nobody can
bother me i'm ready
as i'll ever be i love it uh for those
that don't know you let's start with uh
your background
and uh kind of what you did before you
got into uh crypto
yeah so my name's tor uh i now
work at secret foundation we focus on
adoption of open source
privacy preserving technologies such as
secret network
uh so i'm passionate about privacy uh
overall and that's one of the things
that kind of got me full time into the
crypto and blockchain space
overall the idea of individual
sovereignty
which gets thrown a lot around in the in
the blockchain space people being like
be your own bank
and things like that i was very
attracted to the bitcoin ethos
but then i kind of discovered that a lot
of people
don't really understand what it takes to
actually be
self-sovereign and it does take a degree
of privacy and right now privacy is
essentially a luxury good
the world over the way i see it privacy
should be
a public good and if we can use
technologies like blockchain
to make that a reality for individuals
all over the world not just the
billionaires that have you know like 17
citizenships and jets and whatever
then we've actually done something with
this technology not not just
you know creating a better more
decentralized more democratic financial
system but
just like a a data system an internet
that works better for everybody i i just
want to
i want to make tech that works uh as
good as bitcoin does for money
i want to make other decentralized tech
that works just as good for pretty much
everything in the world
that's that's my dream that's why i'm
here i love that and
so uh for people who don't understand
the importance of privacy
uh let's just start there because i
think people hear that they're like oh
yeah that sounds great like everyone
should have privacy
uh but then when they are faced with
like the consumer trade-off of
convenience versus privacy they almost
always choose convenience
um so maybe let's just start with like
why is privacy so important
yeah privacy is i mean there's actually
a great apple commercial airing right
now i kind of wish i'd written it but
the one where everybody's walking around
and it said
it's a girl with a megaphone and she's
like my credit card number is
742. or like there's a guy who's talking
about all the divorce attorneys he's
written that morning
i think it's a great ad because again
it's making something tangible for
people that's not normally tangible
the problem for people as you're saying
like they always choose convenience over
privacy because convenience is so
tangible
i want to use facebook to connect with
all my high school friends i don't want
to have to set up like a command line
interface and
do all kinds of crazy stuff just to be
able to know that my data is not being
sold to cambridge analytica or elsewhere
that's that's never going to be
something we can ask consumers to do
consumers will always choose convenience
the problem is that they've never had a
real choice
we've never created a technology or a
platform that also had the network
effects that also had the usability
that protected users we've had things
like facebook or google where the entire
business model is
give you the thing for free now you're
the product now they monetize it
and that entire surplus between the
value of your data to advertisers
and like what it costs to collect that
data all flows to the platform
none of it to the user and the way that
i'm thinking about it is if you give
consumers the choice between two
platforms
that can compete on like usability but
now they're getting more
value directly back from the platform
whether it's like in a monetary sense or
whether they just have more
ownership of the platform itself people
will choose that platform
and and i want them to use that platform
very much but it's not just a technology
barrier we're talking about it will be
it's an education barrier as well so i'm
i'm ready to fight that battle but as
you said it's it's gonna be a battle
yeah and what it feels like is uh there
are some technologies in like the
centralized world that are realizing
the only way to get people to have
privacy kind of preservation
is to build it in and use the company's
ethos right so apple is a great example
of one
there's some others um do you feel like
uh there's enough companies like that
or is this something where the users
ultimately are gonna have to make the
decision like
this is important for me and i can't
rely on other companies to do the right
thing and therefore like
i make the decisions rather than just
use products that happen to have privacy
prevention
or preservation built into them i
think that there are plenty of companies
that have the right ethos
i don't think that they're the biggest
companies in the world i don't think
that they have monopoly power
so even if you have every consumer in
the world like there was a time when we
thought everybody was just going to
quit facebook one day because of the
cambridge analytica revelations and i
didn't really believe that would happen
but all sorts of people were thinking
like
this is finally it's going to manifest
all those like 2 billion 3 billion users
are suddenly going to migrate somewhere
else
facebook has effectively monopoly power
for the thing that it does
you know it's it's a duopoly with google
for the entire online advertising space
so even if you have a smaller company
like a duckduckgo or what have you that
has more of a privacy-centric ethos
you know that's not enough you can't
just have like a you can't compete
with google or facebook and use privacy
as your differentiator
so ultimately it doesn't come down to
like will customers make that choice
well consumers make that choice
it's whether we're going to have a
society in an economy that allows there
to be
any degree of competitive choice i think
the question you're asking has a lot to
do with how
how we're going to allow monopolies and
surveillance capitalism to be
pervasive and if we're totally cool with
where we are now if we're just like
that's fine five companies that's it
that's all we're ever going to need
you know that's the choice that we're
all making but i would prefer to think
that you know
consumers will first make the choice
that hey maybe
having amazon and facebook be the most
powerful entities in the world
no longer like global governments maybe
that's just as bad perhaps
worse and then they start thinking about
what is this third alternative
maybe something that's closer to the
blockchain space where there are more
things that are community-governed
that are user-centric only then can we
start to have the conversation around
how are we going to have platforms
and companies that can compete directly
with facebook and google not not as like
a traditional corporation
maybe but as an ecosystem that is so
user-centric and rewards users so
directly
that they just want that value and
they'll compete on that
makes uh makes a ton of sense and
obviously there's a whole bunch of
different uh projects and blockchains
and
uh cryptocurrencies that are focused on
how do we use technology to
uh increase privacy and protect people
one that people are probably not
familiar with and frankly i'm not
nearly as familiar with it as you are is
uh secret so maybe talk a little bit
about just
what is being built there what has been
built what are the
kind of uh vision or ideals and ethos
that the community is going after yeah
that nothing would delight me more than
to get to talk about that so secret
network
uh is one of these projects in the
blockchain space that's primarily
concerned first and foremost with
how do we bring privacy to users because
we believe in it as a human right but as
i said earlier
also has a public good if you look at
the state of like most blockchains
pretty much every blockchain by design
blockchains are bad at privacy
like they're designed to be auditable
and transparent like the idea of an
open financial system with bitcoin you
know
it's wonderful anybody can kind of set
up their own node their own wallet be
their own bank etc
but at the same time that you're being
your own bank you're also constantly
tweeting out your bank account
so you have every transaction you know
even if it's pseudonymous right
it's all traceable back to this address
and
it's not about i i say this a lot when
it comes to privacy it's not about
wanting to hide something
it's just like it's a security threat
when you do something like that or as
the apple commercial is showing you like
there
you just want to have a choice you want
to be able to say this can be public
this can be private
right now blockchains are kind of worse
for privacy than anything that came
before them because there is no choice
all data is public by default so secret
network
is a new kind of blockchain and the way
that it works
is that similar to ethereum it's a smart
contracting platform
but unlike ethereum everything that
happens on the platform is private so it
would be if you
combine the programmability of a
platform like ethereum
with the privacy of something like zcash
or monero you would get what secret
network is
and the reason you haven't seen
something like secret network before is
not because nobody thought of it or
because nobody thought privacy was
worthwhile
it's because this is one of the hardest
technical problems to solve
in the space and we've been at it i
would say uh secret contracts as we call
them this privacy preserving smart
contract
stuff has been in development for the
past three years and it's only now
september 2020 that it's actually
finally coming to mainnet
and that's why i'm excited in particular
to be talking about it because it's no
longer just
one of those pipe dreams right like it's
going to be in production people are
going to be building stuff it's going to
be in the wild
and that means we're bringing privacy to
the people
and so talk through like use cases right
so when people hear kind of these
general purpose
private smart contracts uh they're like
i have no clue what that means
right and and so describe kind of the
use cases in which somebody would
implement uh something like this and
kind of what the value proposition
to that person uh would be
yeah i i'm happy to answer that i'm
going to answer it first by reversing
the question but then we'll get into
some specific use cases
like i like to ask people like because
they're like what am i going to ever use
this for like consumers don't even care
about privacy where is this going to be
i'm like well they do care about privacy
it just manifests a little differently
like imagine you want to build a
decentralized uber
uh if you do that with blockchains right
now basically if you want to implement
that
you're giving your home address to
everybody not just your driver
right with centralized apps there's all
kinds of permissioning involved because
they're centralizing it in a giant
database if you want to make a
permissionless application
that works the same way and build it on
just ethereum for example
it's not going to work everybody's going
to know where you live it's similar for
decentralized finance applications that
we're seeing today
obviously massive growth right now in
the decentralized finance space people
are you know
lending stuff doing super high leverage
trades decentralized exchanges exploding
and it's all public and i'm asking
people why would you choose to like
use this publicly it's a huge security
risk it's a risk for liquidity providers
on these platforms
uh you can get front runs so easily it's
actually kind of disastrous and the only
reason it hasn't imploded yet
is because there's really no other
choice like people are just like they're
so driven to speculation that they're
willing to compromise their own privacy
so where i see some of the key use cases
being is basically anywhere there's
already been a decentralized application
built
you know imagine it with privacy so that
like we have the same standards in this
space that we do in the regular world
like build a decks with privacy so that
people can't just like
follow your money around all of the time
you know which is which is a huge
security risk for anybody
but also like access control is another
big one people want to build a
decentralized spotify
you try to do that with something like
ethereum right now the best people are
really able to do
is like okay uh you you subscribe pay
some crypto to some smart contract we
will send you back the link to some
content
great now you have the link you can
share the link with anybody that you
want
it's it's not a closed system because
it's all
public by design but with secret
contracts you can have access control
meaning you could subscribe to a
particular like source of this link
the link would only ever be encrypted
and therefore you would you would
probably be able to say i am the only
person with the access to this content
so for artists and content producers you
need something like secret network to
exist like let's say you're trying to
build like a patreon competitor too like
this is the kind of fundamental protocol
level innovation that's going to have to
exist if we want to meaningfully compete
with the centralized world
otherwise it's really just still a toy
yeah and i guess as part of this like
to me these are the technologies that
the end
user has no clue whether they're being
used or not
it has everything to do with the
developers and the entrepreneurs who are
building the products would you agree
with that
definitely and i i'm always saying when
it comes to privacy like the choice
should never be in the hands of the
users like the default choice
the responsible ethical choice for
developers to make when building their
applications is allow it to be privacy
by default
and then the users can opt out but
that's not the way that like
literally every platform works today
and so as this technology gets developed
right one of the things that i'm really
interested in
is uh we see a privacy technology
that's built on this secret network does
this
force the hand of other blockchains
other development teams
to start to implement kind of these
general purpose secret
smart contracts or is this something
that can only be built on the secret
network
that's a great question uh so one of the
things that's really important to us
is interoperability which is to say like
we didn't build secret network to say
like remember ethereum
remember bitcoin okay they're dead now
everything is secret
like it doesn't make any sense and
obviously like what we're going for is
we're trying to find the individual
users and the individual developers and
the individual entrepreneurs
who are already in these ecosystems we
want to show them how to integrate
secret network with their own projects
uh they can choose of course to build
entirely on secret network we we have
our own independent consensus so like we
have a standalone application universe
but we're building bridges to ethereum
we're building bridges to the cosmos
universe
we'd love to build bridges to other
ecosystems as well like as the demand
is there and the idea is that like we
can bring privacy
the way that we've designed secret
network is to bring privacy
to every public blockchain without
feeling like
you know we have to tear down what's
already been created to do it like
privacy is something you can infuse
into these existing technologies and
ultimately privacy is not destructive
it's always additive and the way i see
it is it's always to the benefit of the
user
and historically in the blockchain space
what's been to the benefit of the end
user
has always been what's won out
yeah and and to me the other piece of
this that is uh
is really fascinating is
we're essentially having the technology
pull the users
right in many industries kind of
especially once they reach some level of
uh
maturation what you get is the users
start to pull the the technologies so
people start to say hey we should do
like the lean startup method and
iterative
uh building and we should go out we
should figure out like what is the
optimizations that people want on the
products they're already using
and then we'll create those and that'll
create a lot of value and we can capture
some level of the value that we create
here what's happening is actually a lot
of the
innovation and ideation of these
products is happening from the developer
ecosystem
um and kind of a bottoms up type
approach rather than
you know user-led why do you think
that's happening
in the blockchain is it just like a
we're so early in the industry there's
not enough users yet
is it such a greenfield opportunity that
like where is that coming from
i think with pretty much every
blockchain application you've seen
gain substantial traction the developers
are the users
and we haven't really had to reckon with
the idea that there is this green space
of millions of users that exist beyond
the developers
that are going to have to pick this
stuff up and run with it so you start to
live inside of an echo chamber
where it's devs building for devs and
when you i'm a little biased here but
like if you hand something over entirely
to a team of developers and you
you don't have anybody thinking about it
from the business development
perspective or from like the user
perspective
ultimately they end up designing for
maximum complexity
and everything hooks up to everything
else you get these crazy like integrated
d5 platforms
also a lot of them don't have a lot of
experience in financial markets so they
don't understand why like
a bunch of leveraged products all tied
together and like strapped together with
duct tape is
actually a terrible you know security
model from a financial standpoint like
anything over leveraged ultimately
collapses
so i like to think about sustainability
that's a word i throw around a lot in
connection to privacy
if we want to attract end users
you know not just devs who have like a
different sort of like risk tolerance
function you need to create a
sustainable and secure platform that
they can come to
and be like if i show up here my money's
not going to be gone in a week like a d5
platform that's not going to bankrupt
you because
you you didn't audit the smart contract
yourself i don't go in and look at every
like piece of code on every app i
download onto my iphone i trust that
because it's in the apple store
it has some degree of security and like
if we want retail adoption you know from
end user consumer like i never use
retail as a pejorative
i just mean regular people like i
actually think that like it's a very
unhealthy idea that like devs in this
space will look at adoption relative to
every other product
only in our ecosystem and be like well
we are winning the race
in the super super tiny ecosystem that
we've already created therefore we must
have found product market fit
the only two things i think in the
entire blockchain space that have found
any kind of product market fit outside
of like
you know the very very niche dev
communities are bitcoin and ethereum
and i would be really hard-pressed to
see anything else come close in the near
future
so rather than like me try to say like
i'm going to fix it from day one
like i would just rather see like how
can we help those platforms like bitcoin
and ethereum like
serve their users that they already have
even better expand their presence with
end users
even better so that we don't end up in
the situation where it's just devs
building for devs we create a parallel
universe and meanwhile
surveillance capitalism carries on
without us we wake up in five years we
realize we live in a global surveillance
state and we're all screwed
it feels also like there's this element
of
a lot of the innovation and building
that's happening uh is kind of at the
layer ones right like the actual
blockchains and smart contracts and
things like that
but that has to happen first before the
applications can be
be built and those applications are
likely to pull in the
users right so kind of bitcoin and uh
ethereum have kind of got to that point
now where they're starting to have lots
of applications around it and it feels
like that's what's pulling users in
is that kind of the plan for what you
guys are doing in terms of hey let's
make the functionality available to
developers first
then let's start to get some of the
applications where this is in use
and kind of can be proven out as a
viable use case and then that's when
kind of those end users will start to
interact with it even if they may not
understand that's what they're doing
yeah i mean that's definitely what
worked for ethereum
at first is like having something that
was just
it wasn't even about like they went out
and they paid a bunch of money to a
bunch of developers and somehow like
bootstrapped an ecosystem by paying
people off to build stuff just people
looked at ethereum and they were like
wow what's possible like it was a giant
sandbox for them
they didn't think necessarily about i'm
about to build my billion dollar
business on ethereum they were just like
i can build things i've never been able
to build before on ethereum
and that's the same way i position
secret network for developers who might
be familiar with ethereum or other
blockchains
is to say you can build stuff with
secret that you've never been able to
build on any other platform because we
give you privacy by default
so there's all kinds of like use cases
like i was saying for access control
but anything related to like privacy
preserving voting privacy preserving
auctions privacy preserving lending
platforms where you don't want to expose
everything you've ever done in order to
qualify for some sort of like on-chain
loan
like you could only build those on
secret by making the
technology compelling enough to
developers and showing them how you can
build unique applications in the space
what we're doing is we're letting them
carve out their own role in our
ecosystem
and so they say i'm not late you know
like i i didn't show up late that
somebody's already taken over this
ecosystem it's over they're saying i'm
early i'm the first one in the public
blockchain space
to build this kind of thing and then all
we try to do is say you've got the full
support
of the rest of the secret network
ecosystem and secret foundation
standing behind you we will help you
find that global adoption
we'll help you find the partners who are
going to help you like
bring in the users that are going to
make this project sustainable for you
and that's kind of like the promise that
you have to be making as a protocol
when you are trying to reach developers
in these early stages
it's that two-piece promise of we
promise we will continue to give you
groundbreaking interesting tech that
creates a really cool sandbox
but we also promise to help you find a
way to make this self-sustainable
so that you can continue to build in
this space and feel like you have that
support
got it and so as you go deeper on these
use cases
like i think the probably uh most
obvious
uh use case that people have seen for
the privacy protection
technology has been like privacy coins
and so maybe talk a little bit about how
you see
those interacting with something like
what you guys are building
um are they competitive are they
collaborative uh are they just kind of
completely unrelated
like how do you see uh those kind of
first you know
user-friendly applications of privacy
technology in the blockchain space
uh with privacy coins interacting with
you guys
that that's such an excellent question
because people ask me is secret
a privacy coin and realistically it's
not
i mean it's a privacy platform but it's
it's something that you kind of have to
do a lot of education on because the
word privacy has become meaning like
monero it's like you're sending
something to somebody else
you can't see who sent it you can't see
who received it you can't you know like
that's that's what people think of when
they think of privacy in the blockchain
space
and you know from this conversation i
hope people are realizing like privacy
is so much more it's the way privacy
works in the real world we call it
programmable privacy programmable
privacy meaning
you can have arbitrarily complex like
privacy protections for decentralized
applications you build on the network
and a transaction is just like a really
trivial form of computation like the
simplest form of computation the kind
that bitcoin uses
move value from point a to point b
programmable privacy means not only do
you get that
you get the smart contracting ideas of
ethereum where now like
you can program what you want those
value transfers to do you can like
have smart contracts uh that interact
with other contracts
and unlock themselves right and trigger
other actions you're creating a privacy
by design
like a fully decentralized platform so
zcash and monero are very different
for example from what secret does but
what's possible with secret network
is that you can actually issue secret
tokens on the blockchain
so like you have erc20s on ethereum
right you can send these tokens around
to people they can sit in like your
metamask wallet or something else you
can
trade these tokens you can use them in
applications similarly you can have
secret tokens on secret network
where they work like erc20s they work
just like the tokens on ethereum
except that instead of like at all times
you being able to see
absolutely every token transfer that's
going on just by loading up a block
explorer
on secret all of that is encrypted
because smart contracts on it on secret
network use encrypted inputs encrypted
outputs encrypted state
so when you've got a secret token if you
went to look up that token
you could see for example like how many
people hold it you
and you could see like how many active
addresses but unless you are the owner
of the address that holds that token
you can't actually see the entire
transaction history
what this means is the more people who
use secret tokens and things that you
build on secret network
you are gaining privacy proportional to
the actions of
everybody else in the ecosystem so that
means like basically a global anonymity
set
for all of the secret tokens on secret
network and in this way i guess the
what i've been using lately sorry about
the covid times this is triggering for
me too
but it's like vaccination in that even
if you yourself don't care that deeply
about your privacy just by using secret
tokens instead of something else
you're providing an inoculation for
everybody else who's using applications
on that network every successive person
who chooses to use these kinds of
technologies
is helping protect the security and the
privacy of everybody else
on this platform and it's those kind of
network effects for privacy
that i think make privacy coins that
could be issued on secret network
super super compelling relative to
privacy coins that are standalone like z
cash for monero and so really the idea
here is to kind of use this as a
scalable platform uh where not only are
you
innovating on the actual privacy
technology itself but then you
create these almost like launch pads
right you can come in you can create all
sorts of applications you can create
assets
that are all privacy preserving um you
already mentioned a little bit kind of
the ethereums and the bitcoins of the
world you know saying hey look that's a
great idea around these general purpose
uh private smart contracts they could
potentially um you know try to rebuild
it or just
through the interoperability of what you
guys are doing they can benefit from
some from it
now one of the questions is uh there's
the secret network there's the secret
foundation
and uh and not a secret foundation but
the name secret foundation
and uh and a whole bunch of kind of
developers and things like that
how much of the uh kind of future plans
or outlook is
what i'll call uh kind of holding
constant one side of the marketplace
right so i think of kind of the supply
of applications and then there's the
demand of users
is the foundation the network and the
existing developer community
is the thought process that they'll end
up creating most of the applications
um to bring in those users or is this
something where there's
active activities to go and get kind of
new developers
new uh companies and projects to come in
and build on top of the platform
yeah it took me a second to figure out
what you're asking but actually you're
asking like an extremely critical
question how much do you care about
creating a long tail developer ecosystem
versus building out the key applications
yourself utilizing the key contributors
who are already in your ecosystem
you said that much more eloquently than
i did no i feel like you had it right i
just like
the way to answer that question we have
to look first at like what is the
structure of the secret network
ecosystem so i'll back up a sec
secret foundation we don't actually do
any of the development work right now
for the network we are purely
an educational organization focused on
global adoption
and awareness of these privacy-centric
open source technologies
it takes the burden off us to have to
say like this is our protocol like we're
not taking ownership of the tech
or of the code we're taking ownership of
the community we're taking ownership of
the growth trajectory of the network
like it puts us in a position where we
can focus on what
we want to do best which is help make
sure people actually use this stuff at
the end of the day
meanwhile there's development teams who
contribute at a protocol level
so the key development team in our
ecosystem is enigma where i used to work
and enigma is responsible for a lot of
the secret contracts
code that's now coming to mainnet uh and
that effort is
absolutely critical right like we
wouldn't be where we are without that
kind of development effort in the space
now enigma's focus can turn from not
just supporting development of the
protocol but
what are some of these key applications
that are going to exist in this
ecosystem
but outside secret foundation and enigma
we have over 45 mainnet validators right
now
including people who are super active in
some other ecosystems like staked
figment networks chorus one dokia
capital there i mean there's a lot
there's 45. i can't name them all i'm
really sorry guys
um but there's also people like
secretnodes.org
chain of secrets secure secrets like
organizations that have sprung up just
to serve the secret network ecosystem
build block explorers build tooling uh
we just helped fund kepler wallet which
is
trying to become the meta mask of like
the cosmos and secret network ecosystems
and they're building an integration that
will allow you to use secret tokens
right from your web wallet interact with
secret contracts right from your web
wallet like
those are the kinds of collaborations
partnerships that are essential for
getting that end user adoption and we've
been laying that groundwork for the past
few months
now with secret contracts coming to
mainnet we're finally in a position
where we can say hey
here are the first key killer
applications you've got secret tokens we
have a few other defy applications we've
pushed out there
we have some access control contracts
people can pick up and integrate into
their own applications
we've got these building blocks down now
it's up to the developer community to
tell us how they think these things can
be used
if they come back and they say actually
we can't use these things
then we have to make better building
blocks but if they come back and they
say hey we integrated this in our
application
it runs 10 times faster users are
protected
then we know we've got something we know
we have that product market fit
and then the entire secret network
ecosystem can completely reorient all of
our efforts
around supporting specifically those use
cases in the early stage of the network
so by being a decentralized ecosystem
and being flexible with our roadmap
especially our application roadmap in
the short term
we're ensuring that wherever the user
demand is going
we're going to be there we've talked a
lot about kind of
the short term uh and kind of what you
guys are doing now
talk to me about the you know really
long term vision ten plus years from now
where does this go and kind of how does
it evolve
yeah when i get asked questions like
that it's so tempting for me to just be
like well
we all live in the secret citadel
obviously
uh no it's it's a really interesting
question because it really depends what
happens to the world like
if the world changes over the next five
to ten years dramatically so i think
it's changed pretty dramatically in the
last eight months
um but like look look over the next like
decade what are the trends you think are
going to occur
globally and so one of those trends as i
was saying is what is going to be the
role of nation states versus
corporations
what does that mean for self-sovereignty
and these decentralized networks my
thesis has always been that
we're going to see more and more of a
pull to these sort of
user-centric networks that are
user-owned user controlled
you know not not in an isolating way not
in like
i tore him alone but just like i tore as
an individual contributing within this
community in this context
now have more ownership and more control
of the
organizations that i choose to use on a
on a daily basis
so if that's a trend we're going to see
over the next five to ten years globally
i know that secret network's gonna have
a huge role to play in that
but if we just take like the world of
today and and much like you know it used
to be like
uh you know if people had thought about
what's the henry ford quote or whatever
he was like if
you'd asked people what they wanted they
would have said faster horses kind of a
thing so let's take that for a second
you take the world of today and we just
say well where can secret network plug
into like the enterprise world today
i would say privacy is one of the key
things that's preventing enterprise
adoption of the public blockchain
ecosystem
so even just looking in the next few
years thinking about how can secret
networks start onboarding
more of these enterprises into our
universe and like there's so much that
you can do with secret network just
around like secure data sharing
if you're a bank with branches in
multiple comp in multiple countries and
you need to share user data securely
across
you know international lines because
you're doing some sort of fraud
detection algorithm
like what a like what a simple like real
world use case
but possible with our network you don't
have to go into like a decentralized
lending platform with you know
sushi farming or whatever's in vogue
these days like that's just like a
regular real world use case or like for
example
healthcare since we're in the middle of
a pandemic enigma
built this this product called safe
trace
and it's privacy preserving contact
tracing and contact tracing was a big
topic earlier this year thinking like if
i've been in contact with an infected
individual i want to know
at the same time i don't want to tell
everybody in the world my infection
status
i don't want to tell the government
exactly where i'm located at all times
so enigma built this poc to be able to
say here's a way to do secure
contact tracing and they're actually now
working with intel to
like get that scaled out and and bring
it to market in a more robust sense
things like that can be deployed on
secret network right or they could be
deployed like
privately as well but i think that
applications like that are much more
useful
and in the long run probably the way
that we all want to be going like
those are the kinds of applications that
you want to be decentralized community
owned and so on so that you
so that you can ensure that they're not
held in the hands of like a single
government that could misuse that data
so
there's there's the like 10-year vision
of like or is the world going to
collapse i don't know but even if it
doesn't
there's a ton of ways that i think this
technology is relevant today that i
can't wait to get started uh
you know building just because it will
help expand what's possible with these
technologies versus the
insular world we've lived in for the for
the past few years
what needs to happen uh kind of outside
of your own
efforts right in terms of the the
network and the community
uh to facilitate this or accelerate
right so what are like the macro forces
or or things that can be
tailwinds uh to get there faster
well i would say that education is a
huge piece of this and not just
education of end users but mostly
education of the governments and
enterprises
who to date really don't show any
concrete understanding of how a lot of
the stuff works
i would say education also of uh
tax systems and the irs and things like
that
like if people start to understand like
there's no way to put our
crazy square peg crypto universe in the
in the round holes of traditional
regulation like
we're not out here to do anything crazy
obviously some people are but
and to take advantage of people like
privacy is kind of the opposite we're
here to protect people
if we can help the governments and
enterprises and regulators of the world
sort of understand that privacy is about
protecting the same people that they're
trying to protect
and we get the tailwind of that sort of
support and adoption
from various entities all over the world
i think that would go a huge way towards
supporting like our reach to try to
onboard like the long tail of users onto
these decentralized applications
so long as they see it as a direct
threat maybe to their authority
it becomes a lot more impossible and i
think that there is you know a tendency
in the crypto space to position
ourselves
against the traditional world and say
like okay
we're external we're revolutionaries you
know we have to be
you know reactive to real everything
else that's going on in the world
and i just don't think we'll ever get
global adoption
if that's our attitude and and the
reason we have to have an attitude
adjustment
is we can't allow ourselves to
you know be left out of the conversation
because if you leave it up to the
surveillance states of the world
like we will end up in the dystopia that
we don't like and if we're if we're just
going to bury our heads in the sand and
try to say we're going to build a
parallel universe we don't need the
regulators to understand we don't need
the enterprises to understand
then they're going to build something
without us too and then at the end of
the day we live in a meat space
like we're going to have to live in
their world so unless we learn to work
together and play nice with the rest of
the world
until we can all start living in virtual
reality paradises like
we have to understand that this has real
world consequence and we have a
responsibility to make sure the real
world that's getting built
is the one that we want to live in
what do you think the um
things that could happen that would
change your mind
in terms of this is where we're going
in terms of this is where we're going
when i'm saying like which which part
the part where i'm hopeful that
everything works out for the best and we
do integrate with normal society or the
part where
uh i i'm wrong and everything burns down
uh the idea that you have of like
hey the world is going in the wrong
direction what could happen that would
change your mind on that
yeah honestly what i want to see
is world leaders you know whether you're
a leader of corporations or whether
you're a leader of a financial
institution
or a leader of a country people stepping
up and seeing
saying i see the value in these
technologies for the people
i am responsible to you know like if
you're in a financial institution it's
like we have investors
we have people who have like given us
their capital protect
like for people like that to say like
bitcoin is now my treasury asset
that goes a long way uh for for somebody
who runs the government to be able to
say we are working with the creators of
these decentralized technologies to
build these privacy preserving
applications for our citizens
because we believe this is the best way
to protect our citizens like
people listen to people in positions of
authority
and when right now when we look at the
world i see a lot of people in positions
of authority that i don't
really want to listen to at all because
they just don't understand the
fundamentals of the technologies maybe
that they're talking about but also a
lot of them just don't seem to have the
best interests of the people they're
supposed to protect
in their mind if we get to a point in
the world where
we have had some sort of like on the
ground revolution and now our
governments
do seem to reflect the will of users or
our enterprises our corporations do
seem to exist to protect users and
here's where i think or i hope
apple's moving in the right direction
versus a facebook like
if that's the trend of the world if we
start seeing leaders step up and say we
know this is best for
our users then i'll feel a lot more
hopeful because then i know they'll be
considering all kinds of solutions and
up until that moment what i'll assume is
that they're all behind the scenes
uh trying to collect as big of a facial
recognition database as possible
and that's you know that would be the
downside that's the scary scenario
that's the thing i have to stay scared
of because it's what gets me up in the
morning to keep trying to build out what
we're trying to do
that would be a very very scary world if
that's actually what is occurring
um before we get into rapid fire to
finish up where can people find
you on the internet and where can they
find out more about
secret and all the work that's being
done there
yeah i'm on the internet everywhere it's
uh
it's it's not necessarily what i'd call
a healthy habit but it is a job so
if you go on twitter you'll find me at
tor bear that's
as in boy a i r uh if you want to learn
more about secret network it's
uh scrt dot network
and that links out to our blog that
links out to our twitter which is secret
network
both words uh you can learn a lot on all
of those pages about what's being built
about our ecosystem there's links to all
of our chat and community channels we've
got thousands of people in our community
channels who would love to connect with
you especially if
you're personally passionate about
privacy uh
and uh yeah like i just started up my
own podcast series again i used to have
one
now it's back but we renamed it now it's
called sharing secrets
so i'm super jazzed i mean like i i
think you're best in class dude so i'm
just i'm just trying to do my best with
the interview series and get
interesting people on uh but i love
having people on who want to share some
secrets
uh so if you've got secrets of your own
get on my show man i i would love to
i would love to talk to you i'm down
ah hell yeah all right well now now
we're really talking now we're grooving
sharing secrets i'm down uh i seen two
questions everyone before i let them go
and you'll get to ask me one uh first up
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh my god ever read uh
fiction snow crash loved snow crash got
me [ __ ] scared about
the sorry about that about the uh the
the uh the coming of potential
apocalypse
and then uh on the non-fiction side i
really enjoyed debt
recently like the history of debt that
that was a really interesting read and
i'm trying to remember the author but oh
i read it it's like the 5 000 years
exactly exactly i read that like but i
forget who wrote it
i know it's a big red book and i and i
had it on my ipad and i read it straight
through and it's all highlighted but
that got me thinking about the ways that
money's been used as a weapon
really throughout history and how like a
more open financial system
kind of neuters that and gives the power
back to the people
aliens believer or non-believer
oh they got to be somewhere right i just
don't know if they've made it here yet
if if i was an alien and i saw earth and
i was coming i wouldn't be in a rush
if you were an alien and you saw earth
you wouldn't be in a rush
i wouldn't be in a rush to get here man
i would be staying wherever i already
was
if you were a human and you knew where
the aliens were would you be in a rush
uh if they were willing to like take me
in
i'm kind of nice i'm looking for some
alternative planet options at the moment
just in case this one doesn't work out
i know this guy uh elon musk i think
he's looking for the same thing he's
identified one he's trying to get there
yeah and i invited him on my podcast he
hasn't gotten back to me
maybe he doesn't have any secrets we'll
give him some
uh what question you have for me to uh
to finish up
man i guess the best question i have for
you is like throwing some of the stuff
you've thrown at me like
right now are you an optimist or are you
a pessimist like you've been in this
space a while too you've been talking
about bitcoin forever
you're starting to be and i've always
thought of you as the kind of person
who's thrown open the door for like
these legacy institutions to dip their
toe into the space
you know so are you an optimist right
now or a pessimist when you get feedback
from them when you see the way they're
looking at bitcoin decentralized tech
right now do you think they're finally
starting to ask the right questions do
you think they're seeing bitcoin the
right way
or are you worried that they're gonna
start running the other way
uh just just because of the state of the
world are they just going to like tunnel
tunnel back to what they were doing like
the traditional world and sort of uh
try to try to ride all of this out the
way they've always done
yeah i i think long term like i'm an
optimist right we live in the most like
prosperous safe time in history for
humans and
you know the world has generally gotten
better uh
over very long periods of time uh in
terms of
crypto specifically in bitcoin um
i kind of just think it's happening how
it's supposed to happen right which is
it just takes time people have to get
educated people to get familiar like
there's something to be said about the
fact that the first time somebody hears
about bitcoin they think that it's
you know not gonna be around and then
five years later it's still there
like but it takes five years for that to
like sink in right
that hey in five years it's still here
um so i think there's some of that uh i
think there's a lot of education
obviously it needs to happen
um and then you know some people hate
this but like the price has to go up
there's no better way to uh elicit
people's
attention than to show them that the
market has determined bitcoiners were
right
right and you know that doesn't help
them today
in terms of current prices but like that
is probably one of the biggest
inflection points in terms of adoption
is
the price going up and and so uh it's
not
something where like the price going up
is uh a neces
a necessary um you know kind of
inflection point
but it will definitely be a big one uh
and then the other thing i would just
say is
in general i think there's a lot of kind
of tailwinds right so if you look at the
macro environment stuff with all the
quantitative easing and all the issues
that are going on there
um that forces more people to look at
inflation hedge assets right
you see all the privacy stuff you're
talking about then people can look for
privacy technologies
um you even get into things around like
is centralization a business risk today
right and so you know should i actually
go start understanding what does my
business look like if it was
decentralized and what does that mean
is that my products is that my supply
chain is that my ownership structure
you know is that just i have a lot of
offices around the world like there's no
right answer for a lot of this stuff but
i do think that
those tailwinds you know slowly but
surely push more and more people to go
explore um and then just over time they
end up sticking around right
it's the same way that i got here you
got here and you know pretty much
everybody else got here is
there was a time in our life where we
didn't know about this stuff we
discovered it we
explored and eventually were like ah i
should probably stick around and i think
that's kind of what we're watching play
out
uh the problem is like that's a really
shitty answer for a lot of people
because they want to know what they can
do right now
right yeah no it's for sure there's
always something you can do
right now but it definitely sounds like
your optimism comes from the same place
of mind which is people are starting to
ask the right questions when before they
might have been
kind of ignoring the fact that those
questions needed to be asked at all
so that's progress uh that's the way i
think about it man
is just uh keep making little steps of
progress every day
and eventually you turn around and say
wow we we walked pretty far today
right so the uh be pretty good um
all right s-c-r-t dot network
correct s-c-r-t it's almost like you
just took out the uh
the ease there that's correct and it's
also the the
symbol for the coin so it keeps things
pretty clear we like to say that the e's
are private
ah very clever very clever all right
listen tor thank you so much for doing
this
uh i think that obviously the message
that you bring in terms of privacy is
important
uh and it's something that we need to
preserve and take much more seriously
is an important message so thank you so
much for doing this and we'll have to
get in the future
my absolute pleasure man thanks again